[Music]
Yamato or
carrot bunay or
Viv kakuri or smoker the one piece
Community absolutely loves to deay
potential candidates to join the straw
hat crew So today we're going to rank
them all from the absolute worst fits to
the ones that definitely should already
be straw hats and one thing you may not
even know is that there are actually
quite strict requirements about what
characters get to join the crew these
three requirements are never broken and
each member fulfills all three they are
number one every straw it has to have a
tragic backstory number two every stride
has a dream that can be fulfilled by
joining the crew and number three every
stride must have an actual role that
they can fulfill in the crew and just to
show you what I mean let's take Chopper
who was abandoned as a young reindeer
then he poisoned his friend which is
pretty tragic if you ask me then we have
Chopper's dream which is to be able to
cure any diseases around the world and
then obviously his role in the crew is
the doctor and these three requirements
hold true for every single straw hat
which means that some of these
characters that were're about to rank
would make absolutely no sense to join
the crew While others are actually
pretty perfect fits and so let's kick
this off with the absolute worst
candidate that fans thought might
potentially join the crew because at
number 18 we have actually the gassy
scientist Caesar the clown which yeah
sounds crazy but there was a time that
people actually thought he might become
a potential Straw Hat now as you might
remember we actually first met him as
the main villain of the punk Hazard Arc
and of course he did some awful things
which we will never forgive him for like
kidnapping children and experimenting on
them later on though he did prove pretty
helpful to the crew like when he helped
everyone Escape big mom's tea party and
so let's just pretend that somehow he
was actually let into the crew How would
would he have fit as a member of the
straw hats well first of all we already
know that Nami would never get along
with Caesar for kidnapping and
experimenting on innocent children and
creating weapons of mass destruction
however his usefulness as a scientist is
of course impossible to ignore he easily
helped Heal The Poisoned Mings on zo and
he also helped Chopper improve his
Rumble ball technology so yeah he could
be pretty handy to have around but he's
still just really a scumbag and the crew
will probably never let him in and
really just slightly above Caesar is
another former villain who has actually
traveled on board of the ship multiple
times which is the Swampman kadu and
yeah I do promise that these candidates
will get way better as we go down the
ranking but kadu is another straightup
evil dude who spends most of his time
trying to kidnap mermaids to sell at
slave auctions which is pretty messed up
and should pretty much make him an auto
no to join the crew but somehow he keeps
ending up on on the ship even right now
after leaving wano which has led some
people to wonder if he could eventually
actually join the crew and for the
purpose of this video he would honestly
be pretty useful to have as a straw hat
I mean his loia swamp Powers act as a
sort of pocket Dimension so he could
sneak the entire crew into places that
they might not be able to reach
otherwise Beyond his loia powers though
he is pretty weak and could probably be
defeated by any decent fighter with
hockey plus he has no real role to
fulfill on the crew so I think hopefully
goodbye creepy Swampman and luckily
these candidates are getting way better
now because next up is gon and it has
been a long time since we saw the most
beautiful alfro in the story because
Luffy Zoro and Nami stopped at this
island way back before they rescued
usopp's Hometown and now this has
happened over 25 years ago which is way
before most of us were reading or
watching one piece or were even born I
guess for some people I mean at this
point in the story Luffy was just
picking up crew mates left and right
from every single Island he stopped that
so it would have been pretty reasonable
to assume that gimon would join as well
and with his love for treasure chests
gimon would have been a pretty decent
crew mate to be in charge of the crew's
money and gold so basically a sort of
Treasurer beside that though he is not
really a fighter at all although maybe
he could have been some kind of powerful
animal trainer I guess anyway none of
these candidates so far would have
really affected the story all too much
at all but that all changes with our
next candidate right here who is mon
Blan Cricket now when we first met
cricet he was living on the edge of G
searching for the legendary City of Gold
and while the straw hats eventually
actually found the Golden City up in the
sky cricet was at one point considered
to be a very likely new member to join
the crew and honestly he would perfectly
fill a super important role which is
that of the lock bookkeeper because as
we saw during the samurai Odin
flashbacks it is super important for
someone on the crew to keep track of the
crew's Journey so that people who come
after will know what actually happens
and as you know the straw hats actually
never have had that so if cricet would
have joined the crew this could have
changed the way that the entire world
views the straw hats for example I can
just imagine cricet keeping records of
the cruise adventures and those records
somehow being shared with the world so
that everyone would know just how good
the straw head crew really is and even
though of course it didn't end up
happening I'm a little bit sad that this
Chestnut headed dude just didn't end up
joining the crew which is the exact
opposite of how I feel about this next
candidate that's because Rebecca was
heavily heavily speculated to be joining
the crew during the entire dress Rosa
Arc and to be fair there were a ton of
characters people thought might actually
join the crew during this Arc but
Rebecca is the one that I always heard
about the most and even though she is a
decent fighter with her expert sword
skills she isn't exactly strong enough
to make a real difference in any major
fight and I probably rank her even below
the weakest of the straw hats she also
doesn't have any clear role on the crew
and we certainly don't need any more
scenes of her crying since we had so so
many of these during dress Rosa now this
next Canada though might really surprise
you because this person is the first of
many many marines who had some point in
time were thought to possibly join the
crew that is of course Kobe here who was
literally the first person that Luffy
ever met after sailing out on his
Adventure Kobe has changed quite a bit
over the years probably more than any
other character but he is almost the
perfect straw head candidate if you
think about it he has a truly tragic
backstory where he was forced to be a
slave on a pirate ship for years he has
grown incredibly powerful so if he were
to join a straw crew it might be
somewhere close to the level of the
likes of Zoro or Sanji but it is
actually Kobe's determination to pursue
his dream of being a marine Admiral that
will always always prevent Kobe from
ever being a straw hat because he is
never likely to become a pirate and no
pirate means no straw hat crewmate so
sorry Kobe you'll probably always just
be a friend and while this next
candidate here never fulfilled the straw
head requirements like Kobe did that
didn't stop tons of people from thinking
that he would actually join the crew and
I'm talking about the Jaguar mink Pedro
here who traveled with the stri to help
save Sanji during the hul cake island
arc and it was during that time that
Pedro showed off how useful a crew mate
he could actually be he was incredibly
intelligent an excellent fighter as well
as having a lot of knowledge about the
entire New World Plus since he was too
young to actually go and travel with the
first pirate king Goldie Roger it just
made a ton of sense at that point that
he would at some point travel with the
future pirate king by joining Luffy's
crew unfortunately Petro is the one
character in this ranking who could not
join the crew because of yeah death
because Pedro made the ultimate
sacrifice when he blew himself up to
allow the rest of the crew to escape
from Big mom's territory and so while we
don't know if Pedro might have joined
the crew if he had lived he was
definitely a strong strong candidate
while he was still alive although while
p would have been a strong addition to
the crew there is no one in this entire
ranking that comes close to the impact
that this next candidate would had have
had they joined and I'm talking of
course about the former Admiral Kuan who
many fans had hoped would actually join
up with the straw hats after leaving the
Marines during the time skip now those
hopes were pretty much ruined early on
though when we learned that Kuan had
actually joined up with Blackbeard's grw
but it would have been like incredible
if the ice loia fruit user had become a
straw hat I mean if we're being real
he's pretty much one of the top 15 or
maybe 20 strongest characters in the
entire history of the story so adding
him to the crew would make future
battles a lot easier I mean just take
the battle against kaido for example
probably I'd rank Kuan above Luffy
before he had his gear five power up so
adding him as a fighter on the crew
would have just been an incredible help
since he could fight top commanders and
even Clash on the level with Empress
which is just extra helpful because
Luffy often needs some time to rest
during his battles however Kuan doesn't
really have a clear role on the crew and
we don't really know what his main goal
at the moment is we do know that he
joined Blackbeard but there are always
theories that he's still just undercover
for the Marines or some other objective
that he has and on top of that Kuan has
always seemed to be trying to figure out
what exactly it means to enforce his
sense of justice so it is a really fun
idea to think about but Kuan was never
really likely to join unlike the
characters coming up for the rest of
this ranking for example we can say the
same for Paulie because during the water
7 Arc he was most people's number one
option to join the straw hats I mean
they were already looking for a
shipright which he is and he was a
decently strong fighter plus I guess he
has somewhat of a tragic backstory If
You Can Count a huge gambling death as a
tragic backstory but in the end it just
didn't happen I for one would have loved
to see him on the crew though for a
couple of reasons one his rope action is
just an awesome skill that no one else
in one piece has even though it isn't
even a devil fruit plus he's actually
pretty modest when it comes to women
like when he demanded that Nami put on
some more clothes so he would have been
a nice contrast I guess to some of the
more perverted gags from Sanji and
Brooke but man shout out to our next
candidate who is keimon because this man
basically traveled with the crew for
almost 400 chapters more than a third of
the story and he has been a major part
of the group ever since we first met him
all the way at the start of the new
world on Punk Hazard as a farting pair
of legs all the way up through the end
of the wano arc and being a samurai from
wano he is a pretty strong fighter who I
drank around average for the straw hats
and honestly we don't even need to
imagine how he would have interacted
with the crew because he was with the
crew for such a long time he is pretty
much friends with everyone and it would
have been great to have another
swordsman on the crew as well though I'm
being honest I'm glad we don't have his
pervy personality joining the crew
however his dream of saving his homeland
wano has now been accomplished so he
doesn't really meet the requirements of
having a dream anymore now that all
changes though when we talk about our
next candidate because MOS has almost
all of the same qualifications as kimon
except even better for starters he did
travel with the crew for a long time
just like kimon but with his recent age
up in the story and his Ultra powerful
Dragon devil fruit Momo would certainly
have been a Powerhouse fighter to add to
the crew and he even has a pretty solid
dream of wanting to explore the rest of
the world which means that he would have
been the perfect lock book keeper just
like his father was on Roger's ship as
well so yeah he may be a pretty logical
Choice as the next Tri candidate in the
end though he did stay behind as the
Shogun of wano instead of becoming a
straw hat and honestly I would even go
so far as to say that Momo is an even
better candidate than our next potential
straw hat on the list but I just can't
get over the fact of how much I would
have loved to see katakuri join the crew
now he was Luffy's main opponent during
the whole Kake island arc yes so you
might be wondering why people thought
that he might join the crew and the
reason really comes from the very end of
that Marathon battle he had with Luffy
Because by the end of this fight kakuri
had become a major believer in Luffy so
much so that he even seemed okay with
Luffy eventually defeating his mother
and the big mom Pirates and this slow
Bel in Luffy fueled a lot of speculation
about katakuri possibly becoming a
future straw hat and honestly he just
seems like a perfect candidate to join
the crew he's obviously a top tier
fighter on par with Zoro and Sanji and
his pretty chill personality means that
he could get along with pretty much
everyone pretty easily his Mochi devil
fruit could also be an infinite food
source so no more needing chopper as
emergency food and he could easily
inherit his mother's dream of creating a
world where everyone can live freely
plus he even has a tragic backstory
although being bullied isn't quite the
same as losing your parents and everyone
so he basically does check all of the
straw head boxes but sadly enough it
does look like the closest that will
ever get to a straw head kak Curry and
one of my personal favorite characters
joining the crew is him becoming some
sort of future Ally but now before we we
get into the top five straw head
candidates who should have joined the
crew we have another really interesting
character with Marco the Phoenix and
this fan favorite character was really
high on everyone's list of possible new
crew mates when the crew came out of the
time skip the reason for that is because
after the former Emperor Whitebeard was
killed and his crew mostly wiped out by
Blackbeard Marco was pretty much a free
agent at that point and similar to jimbe
who did eventually end up joining the
crew Marco was already an ally he was an
older character who knew a ton about the
new world and he was one of the coolest
devil for users in the entire story and
so even though he doesn't really fit the
tragic backstory or having a dream part
of the stride requirements it was always
just so much fun to speculate that Marco
might join the crew kind of similar to
katakuri he's a pretty chill dude who
has already spent a lot of time with the
crew and I bet he would especially get
along with chopper because they are both
doctors even though Marco cheats with
his devil fruit a little bit but you
know that's all right and of course he
would also be an incredibly valuable
crew mate with his ability to heal
injuries helped the crew escape with his
flying and of course his top tier
fighting abilities which even allow him
to clash with Admirals and top yonko
commanders and while this next character
isn't quite as powerful as Marco she
certainly had the entire one piece fan
base completely split in the middle on
whether she should join the crew or not
and I'm talking of course about the very
lovable rabbit carrot who played a huge
role in helping the straw heads rescue
Sanji from hulking Island and then she
just kind of disappeared for like most
of wano but we're not really here to
talk about that we're here to discuss
her fit with the crew and honestly it is
pretty much near perfect like let's be
real she was really good as the role of
Lookout during her time on the sunny her
quirky personality was right at home
with the rest of the crew really the
only thing she didn't have was a tragic
backstory or a big dream to accomplish
so I guess we shouldn't have been too
surprised when she didn't join the crew
and I do have to admit I'm far less
salty about carrot not joining than the
number of characters still coming up on
this list like this next character which
might have been a real shocker if they
had joined and that's because we now
have the Marine vice admiral smoker and
I do know what you're thinking this
cigar smoking dude is still a marine and
he's showing no signs of joining the
crew whatsoever ever but hear me out
first of all smoker has shown up many
many times throughout the story on
islands that the straw hats were also on
such as Alabaster and bazard and pretty
much in each of these places smoka
witnessed the straw hat saving the
country while the Marines slw World
Government were either powerless or
straight up did not care now to be fair
that really hasn't stopped smoker from
keeping on climbing the Marine ranks but
no matter what smoker is always really
trying to help normal people and do what
he believes is right which ironically
enough usually doesn't line up with the
world government's way of doing things
so just wait because when the world
government's dark secrets are finally
revealed to the entire world I really
wouldn't be surprised at all if smoker
decides that he's had enough and flip
sides to become a pirate and join Luffy
now how does he fit in with the straw
hats well he's already pretty familiar
with them due to their clashes in the
past and as a smoke loia fruit user he's
pretty powerful already plus his dream
of figuring out what True Justice is and
saving the people of the world and kind
of how to achieve this is is already a
perfect fit with the straw head's
Destiny to save the world though on the
other hand it is true that we don't
really know if he has had a tragic
backstory and he does have a quite rough
personality that doesn't seem to exactly
fit with the quirkiness of the crew but
if we keep in mind that Robin also
joined the crew pretty closed off and
cold as an individual initially then I'm
sure that someone like smoka would also
eventually open up to the rest of the
crew true so who knows if he'll join
later on but I'm not ruling out smoker
just yet which takes us to the one
character who I don't think anyone would
ever argue against joining the crew and
that is of course Mr 2 Bon and even
without the tragic backstory big dream
or a role on the crew this dude has
literally sacrificed his life for the
straw hat so far more than anyone else
in the story I mean he stayed behind on
alabas so Luffy and the others could
Escape he saved Luffy from death by
poison and nle down and then he let
himself get captured after just having
managed to get out so that Luffy and the
rest could escape from the underwater
prison I mean what a true chat and if
anyone deserves a spot on the crew it is
this man right here but even bonay
sacrifice was not nearly as shocking as
Viv not joining the crew at the end of
alabaster I mean wow W everyone thought
that she was going to join everyone
wanted vivv to join because she got
along with so perfectly with literally
everyone but no she stayed behind to
take care of her country which was a
really sad day for sure but wow I mean
she would have been perfect first her
mom died at a young age and she was
forced to go undercover to save her
kingdom so she has a really tragic
backstory and I actually think that she
would make a perfect Vice Captain for
the straw hats and could even teach
Luffy more about leadership ship which
honestly might have helped a lot in
later arcs like with the family feud
between Luffy and usub in water 7
unfortunately though her dream was
always to save her country Alabaster
which was basically already accomplished
at that point and so besides traveling
with her friends she didn't really have
a solid dream to follow by sailing with
the crew and so as sad as it was to not
see her join at that point she's always
been an honorary straw hat in my book
and who knows she might very well become
a real Straw Hat soon in the future
which of course means that we now have
to discuss the single most controversial
straw head candidate Yamato or I mean
Odin I guess she came on stronger than
any other character by straight up
telling the crew that she was going to
join them and honestly even putting my
own bias aside because I really love
Yamato as a character she does check all
the boxes her father imprisoned her for
basically her entire childhood she would
be an excellent fighter and lock book
keeper just like her Idol Odin and her
dream is to Simply experience the world
after being trapped by her father in a
cage for all her life so yeah I thought
and I guess pretty much all of the fan
base thought that she would join the
crew at the end of wano Luffy even
wanted her to join but for some reason
she ended up deciding last minute to
stay behind however if Yamato should
join the crew later on which was kind of
hinted at kind of like with jimbe I do
think that she would fit right in she's
certainly goofy enough to get right
along with the rest of the crew
silliness plus her devil fruit is just
so awesome I do love the icy wolf powers
and in fact it is one of my all-time
favorite devil fruits in the story but
even Yamato's devil fruit isn't quite as
overpowered as some of the most creative
devil fruits that could break the one
piece world and if you want to see
exactly which fruits I'm talking about
then you could watch that video right
here Shanks for watching and I will see
you in the next one